after days of being raked over the rocks
for promising to spend taxpayer money on
crack pipes the biden administration is
denying that the policy
ever existed at all
hhs just put out a statement clarifying
um around some reports uh that crack
pipes are not going to be part of the
safe smoking kits that are funded by the
administration
but can you clarify for us
were they never a part of the kit or
were they removed in response to this
reporting and this push back
they were never part of the kit it was
inaccurate reporting and we wanted to
put out information to make that clear
they were never part of the kit saki
says the administration never planned to
buy the pipes
which is different from what the
department of health and human services
told us
they never denied that they had planned
to buy the pipes they just said that now
quote no federal funding will be used
directly or through subsequent
reimbursement of grantees to put pipes
in safe smoking kits before that biden's
allies actually defended the free crack
pipes as a logical part of any harm
reduction plan three different stories
who's telling the truth
it's actually pretty simple to find out
you pretty much just need to google
safe smoking kit and harm reduction plan
and then this is the important part
limit the search dates to a few days
a few days ago when the biden
administration changed the definition
and started gaslighting everybody so on
the search day you go from the dawn of
time until three four days ago before
all the craziness and all the changes
now what is a harm reduction plan what
is a safe smoking kit when you do that
one of the very first articles that pops
up is from the maryland capital gazette
there at the very top is a picture of a
safe smoking kit and and right there
quite prominent is a crack pipe
according to the article
there was backlash just like we're
seeing now and the county stopped
distributing the kits
you don't even need to look at the
countless descriptions of safe smoking
kits that mention crack pipes it's right
there in the name by definition a
smoking kit cannot be a smoking kit if
it does not include anything through
which to smoke
this is
gas lighting plain and simple just like
15 days to slow the spread just life
like the safe and effective vaccines
that stop infection and transmission
just like joe rogan the right wing
extremist
it's establishment gaslighting
and they might get away with it i'm glad
you like that clip ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]